hi I'm OBE caballo I play Moana in
because Lana this talented artist that
Walt Disney Animation Studios love to
hide inside jokes and references to
other movies called Pedro what are like
this one you don't have to look under
the seat to spot flounder from The
Little Mermaid did not see that coming
say something you need to see
marshmallow from frozen is the
inspiration for the design of this comic
life also been looking for a flash bro
Zootopia some things are just perfect
for us to drink like this once can you
see anything hitting here like a Kaka
more with facing to look like everyone's
favorite healthcare companions a mesh
kind of cute next time you are
navigating through the movie Moana there
may be even more Easter Egg for you to
fish store until then you're welcome
Oh
[Music]
what generation this peaceful island has
been home to our families are now is a
great danger coming
nagging hands of a hero who journey to
find that demigod Maui
and together they want save us all
[Music]
[Music]
Semmy god of the wind and ci0 of man
what it's actually Maui shapeshifter
demigod of the women see hero of men I
interrupt it from the top heroes men go
in fact going on a mission with some
little girl is my canoe and you will
journey together is not me that comic ok
is a friend of mine first
we've got to go through a whole ocean of
bad Nakamura
kako what
they're kinda cute
I got you back
yes Maori sock
oh really blow dart in my butt cheek
we're going to the Rome a monster don't
worry it's a lot farther down than it
looks
[Music]
you